Oo.
Kaya pasulong, ang mga bit
at qubit ang magiging pundasyon ng computational na paraiso
na magagamit natin para harapin
ang mga kumplikadong problema sa mundo
kaya subukan nating intindihin ang pagkakaiba nila
at saan nanggagaling ang kapangyarihan ng mga qubit
kung titingnan natin ang kaliwang bahagi
ito ay isang paraan ng paglalarawan at gagamitin natin ang mga diagram na ito
sa buong presentasyon para
ipakita ang kapangyarihan — nakikita natin ang isang bilog
at dalawang tuldok, kapag ang tuldok ay nasa north pole
iyon ang zero, kapag nasa south pole naman, isa iyon
iyon ang classical bit na may dalawang estado — ngayon ang qubit ay ang
yunit ng impormasyon sa quantum na mundo
at dito mas masaya ang larawan
dahil ang sphere ay parehong zero at isa
at maaari silang nasa estado ng superposition
mayroon tayong espesyal na trick na available sa atin
hindi lang natin sila maposisyon sa loob ng sphere
kundi isipin mo na bawat isa sa kanila
ay parang isang maliit na buwan
na nasa loob ng sphere at maaari nating i-rotate ang buwan
kaya dito nakikita mo
na ang ibabang sphere ay bahagyang na-rotate
kaya iyon ang dahilan kung bakit makikita mo ang kaunting asul
at rosas at maaari nating i-rotate ito nang buo
kaya ito ay isang daan at walumpung degree na pagbabago
kaya mayroon tayong konsepto ng phase — binibigyan tayo ng quantum ng
tatlong superpower na makikita sa mga qubit
ang mga ito ay ang kapangyarihan ng superposition
ang kapangyarihan ng interference
at ang kapangyarihan ng entanglement
kaya tuklasin natin ang mga ito — ang prinsipyo ng superposition ay talagang
medyo madaling intindihin
kaya ang estado sa kaliwang bahagi
mayroon tayong north pole zero o south pole na isa
at kapag idinagdag natin ang dalawang estado
ngayon mayroon na tayong superposition qubit na may parehong
zero at isa nang sabay-sabay sa hilaga
at timog — ngayon ang kanang diagram ay pareho
pero ngayon gagawa tayo ng maliit na trick
i-apply natin ang isang gate, isang quantum gate
sa ginawa natin dito — tandaan
nagagawa nating baguhin — nagagawa nating
i-rotate ang mga maliit na buwan, tama?
kaya ni-rotate natin ito ng isang daan
at walumpung degree at ngayon mayroon na tayong isa
kaya ngayon kapag ginawa natin ang zero plus isa na pagdadagdag, nakuha natin
ang isang estado ng superposition
pero pansinin na ito ay iba
at ang isa sa kaliwa, mayroon tayo
paring zero at isa pero ngayon may rotated na estado
para sa isa — ngayon ito ay magiging napaka-kapaki-pakinabang
para magamit ang pangalawang talagang kawili-wiling bagay na ito na
ang prinsipyo ng interference
at ito ay isang operasyon na hindi natin nagagawa sa classical
bit na mundo — kaya dito sa halimbawang ito mayroon tayo
zero at isa sa kaliwa kasama ang
bagong estado na ginawa natin
na pati na rin zero at isa
pero may rotated na buwan — kapag ginawa natin ito ngayon
maaari nating i-interfere ang dalawang estado
at pansinin ang talagang kawili-wiling nangyari
na-cancel natin ang estado ng isa
at naiwan tayo sa estado ng zero
nagawa natin iyon dahil ni-interfere natin ang mga estado
kaya ang susunod na pagkakataon na mayroon tayo ngayon
ay ilang estado ang maaari nating likhain
at ang magandang bagay sa quantum ay maaari tayong lumikha ng exponential
na bilang ng mga estado — kaya tingnan natin ang isang sistema na mayroon
limang qubit — sa kasong ito inilalarawan natin ang mga qubit na ito
bilang mga independiyenteng qubit, tama? — nakikita mo sila sa kaliwa
ang mga zero at isa, at pinarami ang mga ito — mayroon tayong lima
kaya ang bilang ng mga estado na maaari nating likhain pababa ay
quantum computer na inilalarawan sa sphere sa kanan
ay dalawa sa kapangyarihan ng
bilang ng mga qubit na mayroon tayo — sa kasong ito limang mayroon tayo
kaya dalawa sa kapangyarihan ng lima ay tatlumpu't dalawang estado
kaya nakikita natin ang tatlumpu't dalawa sa mga maliit na buwan
pansinin na sa kasong ito hindi natin isinama
ang anumang phase — lahat ay rosas — ang makapangyarihang aspeto ng
paggamit ng katangiang ito na tinatawag na entanglement sa quantum na mundo
ay maaari na tayong lumikha ng mga estado
tulad ng inilalarawan sa kanan
kung saan mayroon tayong mga kombinasyon ng rosas
at asul — kung saan ang estado na iyon ay hindi maaaring ilarawan
bilang independiyenteng produkto ng
limang qubit na ito sa kasong ito
dahil mayroon tayong tatlumpu't dalawang estado
ang sinasabi nito sa atin ay talagang isang napaka-malalim na bagay